[Music]
hey guys I'm Nate Berkus and these are
my top ten that's five ten essentials I
believe that people should be able to
have beautiful wonderfully designed
things made out of real materials that
don't cost a lot of money I basically
started my career in design when I was
six and my mom would ask me to come
upstairs in my pajamas and asked me if
there were too many accessories on our
mantle
I think fashion is a really big part of
my world because it's part of my job
really to understand sort of what the
trends are but I always break down what
I'm seeing into terms of what that could
be
so I'm inspired by a window great and
all of a sudden that becomes a pattern
on the top of a bed these are one of my
essentials these are my favorite boots
they're Marc Jacobs they're not made
anymore I think they're 10 years old I
like them all worn in they're molded to
my feet I think they look really good my
grandfather thinks I need a shoeshine so
do you guys remember those little facial
disks that we all used to smear all over
our faces when we had acne and we were
like 15 and it was a nightmare so don't
use those anymore use this this is like
probably one of the best skin care
products I've ever used in my life my
dermatologist that's him right there
David Colbert came up with his skin
disks your skin automatically feels like
younger and fresher good cologne is an
essential good cologne good perfume good
so fleur de Louie these are unisex and I
don't think that you have to wear things
that are just for guys or just for girls
it's really about finding a scent that
that makes you happy
I love reading these are some of my
favorite books this is the last book I
read and I was really enjoying it until
I got to page 142 where it says I can
only speak from my personal experience
but I've been married for 10 years
and barely any gay people have tried to
break up my marriage
I say barely any because that made
Perkis is a little Shady
I'm defenseless against his cuteness and
I for accessories he's always convincing
me to buy beautiful trinkets with our
grocery money thanks Glenn in Melton
another essential for me
is travel and in specific Greece how's
that Patmos which is an incredibly arid
dry really beautiful island where I try
and go every summer to recharge but you
don't have to go all the way to Greece
if you can find a beautiful island in
your mind these photographs were made by
my late boyfriend
Fernando Vanga achaya and they're
hand-woven there were photographs that
he took he was a photographer and then
he took a tweezer and he wove these
together and they're actually about five
feet tall I've always believed that
people should surround themselves by
things that have meaning decorative
boxes are cool these are part of my
collection they all have like little
details metal studs different textures
and things like that but you know in my
own home there's paperclips and post-its
in this one the remote control goes in
this one cuff links and stuff like that
going this one it's just a way to keep
organized this is another essential for
me white tequila to be specific patron
silver and I don't think I really need
to say anything else about that route
essential so one of my essentials is
definitely staying organized in all
areas of life this is part of my
collection that I designed at Target and
these pieces actually keep you organized
but keep you sort of looking good while
you're doing it t-shirts are where
t-shirts almost every day Alexander Wang
I think makes the best t-shirt so this
is Alexander Wang and this one as well
if I really want to shake things up I
can wear this that's kind of the evening
look you got it
you are watching gqueues 10 essentials
which is really I hope you're learning a
lot watching this and you can comment
below down here or you can follow us at
gqueues 10 or even better if you really
are feeling motivated you can subscribe
[Music]